I guess I should start by introducing
myself I don't have my employer listed
on the front I'm doing this in a
personal capacity but I work as a front
office developer at JPMorgan there
commodities business and we use Python
pretty much 100% of our time to build
all our risk management and trading
applications I've been using Python
since 2000 that's 16 years now and have
been using numpy since 2004 and panders
for the last three years so the goals
for today's talk is to introduce the
origins of pandas as bringing together
the best parts of Python numpy and are
and then we'll do some simple analysis
based on sports statistics but we'll go
quite deeply into the typical operations
that you'll do when you do any kind of
analysis with pandas so that would be
looking at data frames slicing rows some
columns from data frames how indexes
work and how group-by works it'll help
you make sense of the syntax that pandas
users and uses a lot of magic syntactic
sugar so that operations that you think
should work just like normal Python do
but with that with a lot going a lot
more going on under the hood and will
give you a sense of what is fast and
what is slow in pandas often it's hard
to know exactly what's going on and that
can make a difference in speed of
algorithms of 2 3 orders of magnitude
and similarly in the amount of memory
you need so this will help you develop a
a good intuition for
how pandas works and it will really help
you the most as you start to work on
bigger and bigger problems with pandas
in many ways if you use pandas just for
very very small data sets efficiency and
performance isn't really a concern
because there's not much work to
actually do it's as you scale it up that
you really need to have a good
understanding of what's going on so to
start with we'll look at comparison
between ordinary Python and numpy so
with plain Python let's say we create a
reasonably sized object in this case a
list with a thousand elements and ask
well how actually is that stored inside
inside the Python interpreter so let's
go back so the it's stored as a Python
object ball python objects boxed objects
so there's a head to the object which
says what's the type of the object and
what's the reference count for how many
names are pointing to it there's submit
data that the object itself has and in
the case of a list it's has pointers to
the individual elements in the list in
this case these are integers and each of
these integers themselves is a Python
object that is boxed so that has the
head that says I'm an integer and how
many different objects are pointing to
me that lets the garbage collection that
that's see Python so so that lets the
garbage collection work now pi PI
for instance will optimize a way that
where it can
and similarly syphon but that's that's
the basics of normal
the cpython now if we do a similar thing
in numpy and create an array this time
we can specify the datatype because we
have much greater control over what's
being used in this case I've chosen a
32-bit integers and that looks very much
the same but it's actually stored in a
far more economical way so we have the
the simple boxed object describing the
essence of the numpy array and then we
have a long chunk of memory that's the
the actual data store and we can see
exactly how this plays out by checking
the size of these objects so the size of
an empty list in Python is 64 bytes the
size of an integer is 24 bytes that this
is in a 64 bit Python so it's using 8
byte integers so the total size of our
list is 37 K so that's for a thousand
one thousand numbers in on the numpy
side it's the size of an empty array is
96 bytes each bytes in this case each
element in this case is four bytes long
and so that the total size of the array
is four times a thousand plus the 96 for
the array structure at the start and so
that gives 4096 bytes that's a far more
economical representation of memory it
also means that from a performance point
of view for lots of operations on this
data we can do we can do working it in a
far more streamlined way for instance
one of the things we might want to do
with the list of integers is to sum them
and
if we do this in Python this time on a
array with a million elements that takes
10 milliseconds and if we do that using
the numpy sum function then that's one
point two milliseconds so that's 10
times faster and that's that gets its
speed because the sum function in numpy
is coded in C and so it operates at the
level of of C tuning through the whole
of that array the the Python one has to
chase through all of these pointers to
the objects unbox them pull out the
integer value and then add it up then go
to the next one and chase out the
pointer and unbox it that's a lot more
work if we apply the standard Python
function sum to our lumpy array then
that actually takes a hundred times
longer or ten times more than doing it
in pure Python that's because before the
the Python sum function all this data
Reiter can pull out the elements from
the list it needs to do the list look up
on the numpy side the numpy will then
box that integer and then it will get
sent to Python and then Python will need
to then unbox it to add it up so this
shows that even though from a syntactic
point of view we're using functions at
all the names the same they can have
very very different performance
characteristics that was the
one-dimensional case if we now extend
the data to the two-dimensional case
then it gets a lot more complex from the
Python the side we have a our list which
is then a list of pointers to other
lists to all of the integers that that's
a one common way to create a
two-dimensional array in Python if we do
the same in pandas sort of in
P we can create just a one single array
we can say reshape it and we've ended up
with an array of integers under the hood
these two arrays they have distinct
headers to each of them but they're
pointing to the same block of data in
memory so array number two here is a
view onto the the memory used by the
first one so we've created a new array
in given it a different shape but we
haven't actually had to copy any data
we've just transformed a bit some of the
structure in there in the head of there
so that's a very very quick operation
and that's that's something that pandas
exploits all the time to get it speed
and just to our to emphasize a bit how
the slicing in numpy is working we can
do more tricks too rather than just
change it some shape we could for
instance here say we want to start at
the third element go through the ends
stepping through every three elements so
we've now got a new new numpy array this
red one it points to data starting at
the third element in and we can see that
by calling numpy dot info on our arrays
and that they the first two have the
same data pointers and the third one has
a data pointer that's incremented by 12
bytes that's three times four so this is
this is pretty snazzy and that's one of
the reasons why lumpy is really you know
the standard way of doing numerical
analysis in Python numpy as well kind of
showed how that indexing works there are
many more ways that we can do it do
indexing take a scalar take a slice so
those are
things that you might see that you do
from with the Python array as well but
we can also pass in set of row indexes
and lumpy noes to pull out items from
those points in the array so we can we
can pull them out and there's a function
called take that does that and we can
also do boolean indexing where if we
have an array that's the same size with
true and false values and then we can
pass that in to take a subset of an
array and we get the the one the
elements that correspond to where this
was true we can also carry that one step
further and when we're taking a slice
like that we can assign values to it so
if we assign minus one to this slice
here you see that we've ended up with
minus 1 values scattered through there
so that's that's really nifty and really
really fast so this is that's the really
the foundation of of pandas and it was
originally built as basically a thin
layer on top of numpy that made numpy
easier to use so it's it's built on
Python Python gives us easy syntax very
easy to learn and easy to prototype
within a shell like ipython as a
reputation for being slow another great
thing that Python gives is a very
helpful community their organizers
meetings like this and that's really
helped to to get adoption numpy then
improved on the slow reputation that
Python had by introducing fast memory
fishing calculations and a whole lot of
algorithms for processing that
and the Syfy project takes that many
levels deeper that now has everything
from basic statistics through to machine
learning algorithms very very rich
ecosystem very very powerful code
because it's all based on lumpy routines
that run basically at C speed very very
efficient now
pandas also brought along one more thing
and that is the concept of a data frame
that borrowed from the statistics
package are now statisticians love R and
going back 12 years ago to the origins
of numpy R was used pretty much
universally by by statisticians Python
not so much and the the useful thing
that are brought to it was ability to
label axes with put labels on rows
labels on columns and add in new columns
as you build up your data analysis and
that was something that numpy made that
was much harder in numpy because you're
dealing with fixed blocks of memory you
could take subsets of the memory but
it's less easy to expand it and there's
really no concept of labeling it other
than through standard Python variables
now if we are if we look at pandas it
started in 2004 as a thin layer on top
of numpy with the basic classes of data
frame series in a time series origins
where's McKinney in quant fund and so
time series analysis is very important
index for being able to look up values
from the data frame and more recently
it's going to grown a whole lot more
specialized
types of classes for operating more
efficiently these are the classes you'll
find if you do import pandas and then
look at what classes are in the
top-level Pender's namespace if you look
in the code you'll find that there many
layers of of more abstruse objects these
are the ones block managers from a file
called cordon internals and then if we
look at a data frame itself it has 425
methods on it so that that is great in
one sense because there's everything
there that you could possibly want it's
not so great in another sense is that
often you don't know quite what you want
and you're left trying half a dozen
different things that sounds
superficially the same especially around
indexing and then you go to stack
overflow and do a search there and find
that there are lots of helpful answers
and there are ones from 2010 that
describe pandas naught point eight that
it's very different from how these
tricky problems get solved today so it
can be a little bit hard to to move
beyond the early early things in pandas
to actually take full advantage of
everything that there is here so this
means that pandas presents a bit of a
they well the there's there's a number
of different things that that the pandas
objects do they have an ability to hide
some of their methods so that they don't
seem to be there if you're searching for
them in ipython and even if you look at
the size of the pandas manual if you
give you if you download the latest
version of pandas get the documentation
as a PDF
I think it's 1983 pages long so there's
a lot of stuff there and a lot of it
actually is not documented right yeah so
in that there's a lot there in in pandas
but it could be hard to figure a way
through it the a lot of the syntax that
you use to do things effectively is made
easy for you but that conceals what
actually is going on under the hood
they're implicit conversions so if it
doesn't do exactly what you want it can
be hard to know how to make it do that
the code base is absolutely massive so
if you want to contribute to it it's
often you you might take a look at it
and think oh yeah I could add this
function and then you get lost in 18
levels of of classes and you're not
quite sure exactly where to begin
and it's also changing rapidly it can do
a lot more the expectations on it
growing all the time and the more people
that use it the more applications they
want to do so a lot gets added but also
it tries very hard to remain backwards
compatible so a bit like an
archaeologist you can dig back through
the all of these methods in in the data
frame and you can see which are the ones
that have their origins and pure and
lumpy and then which have been added
later on and then you can see a more
organized API emerging from that but
that can be hard
see from from all of the detail and the
last aspect is that makes it a bumpy
learning curve is you know sort of big
data everyone is trying to apply pandas
to bigger and bigger problems and
eventually you hit stage where you run
out of memory on a single machine and
you need to think about distributed
solutions or more exotic ways of storing
data on disk using compression and then
you end up having systems that have
pandas like api's but they don't quite
cover everything you want so there's a
lot of power that it can be a little bit
hard to to make full use of at all okay
so that's a bit about the lumpy
background that's the foundation that we
need for starting to look inside inside
pandas and we'll do that by following
through the typical steps that you do in
an analysis in pandas with some
relatively simple sample data and the
typical steps would do would be load the
raw data into data frame would do some
formatting of the columns and add
indexes so we can then start to really
analyze subsets of it then we would
aggregate it and subtotal it using
things like group by and then we want to
display our results so these are the
typical analytical steps so let's follow
that through for some sample data and
the sample data that we're going to use
today is Ozzy rules football there any
Australians here
one down in the corner so there'll be
one person who knows what I'm talking
about is it familiar to you yeah okay so
one of the the unusual aspects of Aussie
Rules is that the scores are always
given as a triple like this and the the
very high scoring game so scores of
around a hundred points are typical you
get six points for a goal and you get
one point for a behind and the total is
the point in this data set this comes
from a website called AFL tables
Australian Football League and they have
a list of results of all football games
since the original Victorian Football
League started in 1897 in Melbourne
through to the latest games from last
weekend so this is a set of fourteen
thousand eight hundred and forty forty
games the two teams here are shown as
home team and away team and then this R
1 2 R 6 these are the the rounds of a
competition is a round-robin competition
and then preliminary final semi finals
and a grand final if you haven't seen
the game it it looks a bit like this
in fact I'll play my short video clip
that you won't hear any noise it's
played on a massive field so it can be
up to 180 metres long there are 18
players on a side so there are a lot of
so it's 36 players on the field
the referees run up and down the game up
and down the oval the whole time so
everyone runs a huge amount during a
game there's a lot of action the one of
the characteristic things is taking a
mark which is this you jump right up in
the air and catch the ball you catch the
ball on the full then you get a
free-kick and the goals at the end of
the field like this four sticks in the
ground and let me turn that four sticks
in the ground two big ones in the middle
those are mark the goals in the middle
is when you get six points if you get
the ball through there if you get the
ball between the small goal posts and
the big ones
that's a behind and if the ball hits the
post and goes in and that's behind as
well so that's what the game looks like
the end result at as you go through the
season is a ladder where they total up
the number of games that are played the
wins the losses the draws the total
number of points for the total number of
points against and then calculate a
percentage and then rank the teams on
the basis of points for for a win - for
draw than for a loss and then resolve
ties for the percentage so our
analytical task for today is to go from
that data starting point to that end
point using pandas and along the way
we'll dive into what's going on we don't
have a ton of time so at various points
I'll skip over some of the details if
you have more questions then either ask
at the end or ask me afterwards and if
you have the slides in front of you then
you can
keep looking in detail some of the
things we might jump first so the the
first step we need to do is to load the
raw data into the data frame pandas has
a ton of functions for importing data
from every possible place and in every
possible format we use this read CSV
function which has a couple of nice
things that you may not be aware of
where we can dump rows at the top so
that header we can take off and if we
specify the engine is Python then we can
use a regular expression for the
separator and we can cope with here
there's a sink a dot in a single space
and between the other columns we have
multiple spaces so with one line of code
we can actually load everything into the
panda's data frame and there it is
that's just like magic
and that's here's the end result so they
just if you imported though using the
sample code this bit in green to save
you typing that in you can just run that
if you've downloaded the data file bg3
then that will load that and import it
into this this data frame if you aren't
using pandas naught point 18 the next
stage this should work whatever pandas
version you're using I think so now
let's look at the structure of a data
frame so if we in ipython if we just
print out the data frame we get
something that looks like this the bits
in red that's the index to the data
frame and in this case it's been added
or to magic automatically and it's a
something called a range index which is
a shortcut that rather than storing 0 1
2 3 up to 14,000 it says I begin at 0 I
end 14,000 and if you want to look up a
value I can tell you where it is because
I'm a smart range index so that's how
that works
the yellow bit is the columns now the
column labels in a panda's data frame is
actually another type of index with with
the names of the columns and it's an
index because we want to when we refer
to a column we need to look up where it
is and and so that's using the index if
we get the d types of the data frame now
lumpy has the concept of a data type for
the data that's stored in array we had
an int 32 and here we can get the the D
types and this shows that the first
column is a 8 byte integer then we have
something that looks a little bit weird
less than M 8 NS and that's the
timestamp with a resolution of
nanoseconds then we have all the rest
are objects and that's because they're
strings normal Python strings and so
they're stored as a reference to a to a
Python object if we do dot values on the
data frame we get back an array or in
this case something called a wreck or a
because it's made of different types of
different types of objects and and this
is is what it looks like here but that
is stored as one single block of memory
there are no pointers to the individual
elements within it like there would be
if we did that in Python it's it's just
the 8 bytes for the first one 8 bytes
for the time
stamp and then a eight-byte pointer to
the Python object representing that
first r1
so is it
in in this case normally in in standard
numpy a wrecker a would store strings
embedded within the array for a fixed
length here they're stored as pointers
so you could change the pointer inside
the array to a different Python object
and then it would look different in the
array now one of the things we want to
do when we have a data frame like this
is to select columns there's the yellow
index along column index along the top
has the names and and we can pull those
out so let's let's compare how long it
takes to get different chunks of the
data array the first one if we do dot
values to get all of this data that
takes 35 milliseconds which actually is
quite a long amount of time because
pandas is hasn't actually stored that as
one block even though you might think so
because a wrecker ray has come out it
stored it as individual arrays using
something called a block manager and it
has to stitch them together and we'll
see that in a moment
it depends what you mean by changing the
size of it sorry
yes so summarize that if you've got
multiple we'll see what happens as we
change these data frames that's some of
the following slides will we'll get onto
that so let's just compare the relative
magnitude of these numbers for a moment
we can pull out one Series in two
microseconds which is pretty fast and
all that's doing is a lot like in the
case of getting a slice from a numpy
array it's basically grabbing the the
memory reference to where that column is
stored and then sticking an index with
that on the top
sticking a copy of Nod original copy a
reference to the row index on the side
and returning it as a panda's series if
we do this last thing in a slightly
different way and put double braces
around it that's what we would use to
select several columns like we do here
and then we're having to build a new
data frame and that takes quite a bit
more time when I did this profiling that
was actually a really big surprise to me
I hadn't realized how much access to an
individual series was optimized and how
much more time it took grouping them
together previously I thought everything
was more efficient if it was stacked
together in a data frame so I would take
a bunch of individual series and want to
put them together and now that tells me
well actually getting an individual
series
really really quick because when you
know what's happening under the hood
it's just grabbing a reference to a
numpy array behind the scenes and the
reason the reason why this is
particularly slow is we have a block
manager and a block manager actually
takes care of splitting up the data
frame into chunks that have homogeneous
data types so in the case of this data
frame we have int block a date/time
block and an object block and they have
these different sets of columns
it doesn't matter to the dumpee that
they come from different columns in in
the in the data frame from non
contiguous columns because they're all
just references to the start of a
different memory location so if we if
we're pulling out values from these data
frames that actually comes you know is
measured in nanoseconds really really
fast by the block manager and if we
compare if we've taken a series the
column home score out of the data frame
and if we compare it with the the raw
values from the underlying block and use
is to compare object identity see they
are referring to the same chunk of
memory so block managers are actually
really neat because they make it really
fast but there's something that most
people that use pandas aren't aware of
so how many people here if you use
pandas quite a bit how many people were
aware of block managers okay so one so
um it's good to know that block managers
are there because that's that's what's
actually storing the data
there's also other things going on with
a whole lot of caching so that if we are
accessing multiple objects multiple
times then we can bypass some of the
lookups now I've put this slide up not
so much to go through the code but to
point out that if you're unsure what
something is going to do in Pender's or
in a pipe and rather put a double
question mark after it and hit enter or
if you're using Jupiter notebook you
could do the same thing and that will
display the doc string for that
particular method and then also the code
so you can see what actually is going on
so you say well I'm trying to look up an
object on the data frame lookup column
by doing data frame square brackets on
the column name what actually is being
called you can look at that and then
trace through a few more levels of it
and then you get right down to the low
level guts of what's going on you don't
that's kind of a shortcut way of
profiling and tracing you don't have to
run anything set breakpoints but it's a
good way of browsing quickly through the
code now if if we are grabbing say a
couple of columns from the data frame to
understand what's actually going on when
we're doing an operation like this it
actually occurs in two steps
the first step is internally it's
getting an indexer for the columns which
given the values we want it returns
integer indexes into the array and then
it does a take function
which says from slicing the array which
bits do I want and and that returns this
thing in blue which is a new data frame
the pandas take function is more
elaborate than the numpy take function
because the the pandas take function
will stick back the columns along the
top and the row index down the side so
that you get back the the same type of
pandas object so that makes your
analysis easy if we selecting rows then
the lumpy same kind of lumpy slicing
mechanism comes into play again where we
are getting a view on top of the memory
and then the pandas is putting back a
row index and the column index in this
case the row index that we want we want
just a little bit of that row index so
that needs to get sliced up as well and
then put back to give us a new a new
data frame but these are reasonably fast
operations to do if we look at the index
on the blue data frame you can see that
it's it's still a range index but it's
now got a different start and a
different stop so under the hood in
lumpy it talked that all kinds of clever
ways to say what's the most efficient
way to to slice something if it doesn't
know how to slice it using some super
efficient shortcut then it will fall
back to creating a full dense version of
that index a full array with 14,000
elements and then slice the bit out of
that so - you know summarize that
selecting a section from a numpy table
is doing a lookup and in the
it's in slicing a dumpy array slicing
the the row index for it and then
putting them back there's some
comparative timings there showing that
the core operation here of slicing the
the data values is something that's
that's very very quick so this is the
first stage of playing around with the
data frame the next stage in our
analysis that we do is we typically
reformat some columns and and then add
some more elaborate indexes rather than
the standard one if you want to avoid
typing in that code you can you can run
this in green from from the sample code
basically what we're doing is we want to
split this into a section for the home
teams and the waiting's so we can we can
grab those we first of all moving three
columns down to an index then use this
rather rather good string extract
function with a new parameter for pandas
18 called expand equals true that lets
us get out these three columns
simultaneously and it returns back a
single data frame so that'll give us a
data frame with the scores three columns
for the home team and in the away team
and here we're giving them with these
named groups in the regex
giving it the names G B and F for goals
behind and then F is for the number of
points for that team and to get the
number of points against that team for
the home team it's the points against
them is the the points for the the other
team
and then we're doing two to step
concatenation firstly just stick the
team name and the schools together to
get a block for the home team in the way
teams and then stick those together
vertically or in this case using a pend
putting an index putting team in the
index because previously we would we had
Home & Away team separate and then we
saw everything so that everything looks
it looks nice and neat and this is sort
of first step towards the the ladder
that we trying to create does that make
sense to everyone it's fairly standard
type of things that you do with with
numpy analysis so when you when we were
doing index with multiple values like
that it's creating something called a
multi index and so then when it displays
the multi index it uses a sparse view
for that and just like a pivot table in
Excel it hides all the values that are
repeated they're actually there in the
underlying data just for display it
hides it and there's an option where you
can turn that back on if you prefer so
I'll just have a brief segue into
indexes and how they use to lookup
values though the idea of an index in in
pandas is a little bit different from an
index in in maybe a sequel database it's
still used to look it up to look things
up but an index is object by itself and
it has a very specific purpose which is
to return integers saying we're in an
array you can find the matching
News and that's done with this get lock
function and it returns either a scalar
or a slice depending on whether the bits
that you want back is is from one
element or a range of elements if the if
the index is monotonic there's any of
you were getting a value back it's
always a slice whereas if the index is
not monotonic then if you want a value
back it may be disjoint and then you get
back a boolean array and these are
things that we can put straight into
index users indexing for a lumpy table
to get back corresponding values very
quickly and that that's what makes
indexing fast the other use of indexes
in pandas is for aligning labeled series
and data frames so if we set up two
series here that have slightly different
labels and then try to add them you see
that we've ended up with nan values
where one of them had a gap and the
other one didn't that's what's going on
under the hood here is that the adding
the two series says these series have
different indexes so it needs to form a
union of the indexes to get a new index
it then needs to re index the a and the
B series discovers that some of them
have gaps and it fills gaps by default
with a nan which is a float in I Triple
E floating point nan so the whole of the
series gets promoted from an integer to
a float and then we can add them
together and that gives us the result we
see if we wanted integers at the end we
would have needed to take care to align
the indexes filling the values with
zeros with an explicit zero
and then they would stay as integers and
we could add them together now in um in
this particular case we have four
different levels of our index and that's
a multi index the three key parts to
multi index is we have the names levels
and the values so the multi index is in
red
the names here is is the names up there
that's the labels that were attached to
them the levels say what are the unique
values that are found in each of them
and then the labels here are integers
that say to each one of these is the
same length as the full list here and so
for instance for the venue
it starts number seven venue number
seven one two three whatever that is
near the start of the alphabet after
Bellerive that's Brunswick Street so
that's how you look that up and you can
use sort of tape functions to do that
they're getting the values for this is
really quick this is five microseconds
and again that's because this is a
homogeneous numpy array
there's no block management magic
involved so it's not like taking thirty
five milliseconds that we had in the
example before now to select subsets of
rows this is one of the areas that can
be most confusing with pandas because
there are many ways to do it
now one way we might do it to say we use
group by two in this case what we want
to say is for our ladder we want to take
the 2016 games and we want to take the
rounds so with a normal round robin and
not the semi-final the grand final so we
want to select
logic like that one way to do it might
be to group by iterate over the table
fix out pick out the ones we want and
then concatenate them together that
takes nearly a second whereas if we do
something like saying looking in the
index to see which values which rows
correspond to the ones we want to keep
and then this would be a boolean array
and then use that in the indexing of the
scores that takes 8 milliseconds so
that's more than 100 that's 100 times
quicker so that shows that if you
understand the numpy origins here you
can get solutions that are way way
quicker here there's so much machinery
numpy involved in pulling out bits of
indexes and data frames and sticking
them together and so on that it takes a
lot of time this is direct and super
fast there's a note here to say that
there's actually a bug in pandas naught
point 18 where this example doesn't work
quite the same as that skip over this
okay so one of the other things we want
to do is one who adds some more columns
one of the things that numpy gives us is
it's just like a dict in python we could
say let's say create a new column for
the games played and for every row
corresponds to a game so we add one in
this case we get this this bizarre
setting with copy warning that you might
have seen and might not have really
understood what's going on but the
reason is that this this data frame here
through the slicing pandas has been
smart and said I can give you a view of
some underlying of the original data
without doing any copying
so when you're trying to set something
to it it's then worried that you might
be changing the original data without
being aware of it
so it gives you a warning about that and
we can we can see that the that there's
a flag on this data frame that says that
it's a copy of the original data frame
that it was built from so if we take a
copy of it explicitly where now this is
copy flag is is cleared and we can set a
new column on it with our without any
warning at all
now if we insert a new column is fast
insert a new column it's actually really
really fast but that's because Pender's
is smart enough to not do anything until
it actually has to so normally it would
stick the new column inside the data
block with other integer columns but it
doesn't want to do that more than it has
to
so it will just accumulate individual
data blocks until you try and do a
calculation then when you do a
calculation it says okay now I need to
put everything together and you'll get a
brief slowdown while it reassembles it
into one block and then it does that
calculation so now we've added the the
games played let's do the wins draws and
losses this this example here shows
various forms of syntax that numpy can
use for doing that and so the pandas can
use for doing that do you think that's
going to give us what we what we expect
not really and that's because these in
this case that was a boolean so we ended
up with a boolean column so we we should
really force that to an integer in this
case that Rd is a new column being
created it's it's ones
but it leaves Nan's puts an ends where
there's nothing else so we can fill
those those and ends with zeros but
that's lifted as floats so we can force
those back to integers or alternatively
before we did that slice assignment we
could create a whole column of zeros and
then the slice assignment would update
the sum of the zeros to ones and it
would also all the state as integers if
we now look at the data blocks that we
have from that each each operation has
each new column has created a new data
block and if we then do something that
will force it to consolidate it in this
case explicitly call consolidate on the
block manager we end up with one nice
tidy block again the the last thing we
try to do is subtitling with group by
and that's actually the syntax in many
cases is is really simple you can get
really complicated if you're resampling
time series or doing custom groupers but
it it's really simple we can then add
some extra columns at the end and then
sort by those values rather than by the
row index and then just reduce the
number of decimal places and we've got
the end result so that's um we have
actually achieved what we set out to do
which is pretty good just before we
finish up this code that did all that we
saw had an example before we're group by
was pretty slow if we took all the
different chunks and concatenated it it
was 200 milliseconds if we do it all in
line like this it takes just four
milliseconds so that's 50 times faster
which is which is pretty good
and there and the reason why is that
inside if we take this this group by we
could split it into two parts so the
first bit is actually getting a group by
object and then applying this function
to it at the end and the group by
function is it figures out what the
groups are and then for each group
it has index offsets into into the data
array and so if we then do the sum
function on that that's smart enough to
look up these indexes and call that
directly on the original data it doesn't
actually slice data frames create new
data frames to give them back to you
this this sum function jumps back inside
so that's that's pretty nifty so this is
the end the conclusions I think pandas
is is pretty powerful like it can do a
lot and it can do more all the time and
often it can do that in a very few lines
of code the problem is that there are
many many different ways to achieve
similar things and many of them are not
very good and to help understand why
some are better than others it is really
helpful to understand what's going on in
the core of numpy beneath it to get this
intuition for yourself
play around in ipython or Jupiter
notebook and try scaling up to really
big problems if you do it with small
data sets with a hundred or a thousand
rows everything will perform you know
kind of fast enough once you have
hundreds of thousands millions of rows
then then it really gets interesting
don't be scared to look inside the code
use the double question mark thing at
the end of a
objects or a method name inside ipython
to quickly see what the code is doing if
you want to try some things at home here
are some ideas for how you could try
putting some of the design principles
from this talk into action in in
slightly bigger problems so that's
that's the end of the talk are there any
questions I think we have about two
minutes left
yeah
so that here okay so if we were doing
slicing on a two-dimensional array would
need to put in X and y-axis or all rows
and columns and in this case this is
saying X is 0 I want to do just the
column and then here the column needs
effectively a tuple with four slices
within it if we didn't put X's equals
zero we would need to make this a a
Pender's an index slice object and then
a comma and then a colon to get all of
the columns you can yes this is this is
just to remove this is just to simplify
the syntax
no no lock is youth for label based
lookups on rows or columns either index
I made one small contribution a year and
a half ago and then my work totally
dominated my life I always wanted to get
back and contribute more and so I
thought preparing for this talk would
give myself the understanding to come
back and start contributing in a more
substantial way and hopefully it will
help some of you guys get going as
painless contributors to Thanks